this Friday
Earth will never be the same
it's only a year it just wants to be
immersed in human Culture by being your
husband my pretend husband you have to
have sex with it or that is disgusting
it doesn't even have the equipment for
that
welcome home son come give your father a
hug that thing is not my dad
none of us were prepared yeah we just
have to adapt with our technology humans
can enjoy a new era of prosperity it's
not real food they print it do you want
me to cut that for you we would rather
live in a cardboard box and be some
gooey coffee tables
turn the paddles down
disrespecting me
look around the world unless if it seems
like a place anyone would want to be at
some point he starts being domination
deep down in there they have hearts I
know they did I literally think they
don't have circulatory assistance period
I don't know what to say then landscape
with invisible hand rated R only in
theaters Friday